jamie is with us jamie is in scranton
pennsylvania hi jamie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i uh wanted to ask you about a
little bit of a
travel plan on buying my first home
i have enough cash to buy it
cheap fixer-upper and pay cash without a
mortgage
but the problem i have is i need a
garage
on site big enough to run a small
business out of um and i can't afford a
property with a big garage and a house
so i have to figure out if i'm better
off buying the house paying cash
than financing putting a building up or
the other way around
well i guess it's uh if it's the same
amount of money that you're going into
debt either way
it's just whichever property you want to
end up with right
i guess but the being self-employed it's
very difficult to get a mortgage
um i was kind of figuring that if i had
a property and held the deed to it it'd
be easier to get a loan for the building
no no no it won't be the exact same
thing because in both cases
if you're struggling to get a mortgage
you're going to be going to a local bank
rather than a traditional mortgage
company
so of course the other option is to uh
you know buy a property to live in
and rent your garage somewhere else well
the the problem
the problem i have with that is i'm i'm
sick of renting um
and i have a i have a young son that i
take care of every day he comes to work
with me now
and i'm reeling that realizing that in
this post-covered world we're going to
live in that they're going to cancel
school for
any time somebody gets the sniffles so i
figure
i'm better off being prepared to have
him there every day with me
right you know you understand what i
mean i want to be able to to work and
and live in the same property so for
that
you're a single dad no no his mother
works full-time
and i take him to work with me so he
doesn't have to
go to day and stuff like that
so i'm i'm a full-time dad part-time
business owner
i guess you would call me you sound like
somebody that's on the back end of a
really frustrating
trying exhausting year and who is just
fed up with the way that uh the politics
and the schools and all that's being run
especially up there in scranton
and i would suggest not going into a
long-term
debt a 5 10 15 20 year
commitment financially over a a current
just an exhaustion and a frustration
right now you know
i i agree i i don't know when
uh schools are going to normalize but to
project that they're never going to
normalize is
is not accurate right um
and uh i don't know exactly what's going
to occur but
is the entire public school system in
america going to be
uh apt to shut down with sniffles from
today forward no is it in some places
right now
yes is it not in some places right now
yes
i mean we're in middle tennessee and
it's pretty well open yeah and they're
not
freaking out they freak out more about
tornadoes than they do covered right now
and so um
uh more likely to shut down for that uh
so
that that's to tell you that it has
normalized here i guess if if you want
to call the phrase
if normalized is a good word i'm not
sure it is a good word but anyway
uh to to dr john's point jamie i agree i
would not
uh build a life around this current
circumstance
i wouldn't build a a debt and a home
purchase around this current
circumstance
um and uh but it sounds to me like you
just don't want to rent and you're using
this as a justification too so
i'm buying a house and renting a garage
and if kid's got to go to work with you
a couple times while you
rent the garage i just do that and um
especially while this is a part-time
business yeah
yeah um or you know buy a house and have
a small mortgage on it that's got a
garage i don't care
and you can get that at your local
credit union or whatever
and if your wife has a full-time job and
makes an income
and you have a part-time business that
makes a profit that you pay taxes on
properly
you are bankable for a loan in that case
if you're trying to
make zero money on this garage and show
that on your taxes because you're taking
everything under the table
then uh you need to do your taxes
properly and not take it all under the
table and that'll help you get the loan
by the way but you're also supposed to
be paying taxes on that money
or you're really not making any money
you're not making a profit legitimately
in which case you're not bankable
so that's another thing and oh in which
case you wouldn't need to be renting a
garage either yeah because then you want
a garage for a cool hobby
uh where you're building something or
making something that you like but
you're not making money on it exactly